a new initiative called power up has
been set up to support 40 black music
creators and industry professionals
the program aims to address racism in
the music industry
and achieve better representation across
all sectors
some of it is nuanced some of it is very
subtle
and then there's in your face blatant
things that happen
one of the main barriers that stuck out
to me
because i'm a black female is the um
ongoing and almost historical barrier
that black women
in music have faced
uh well one ambassador of that
initiative power up is
sabrina washington the former lead
singer of mystique she's going to be
joining us in
just a moment but first let's have a
listen back at one of their heads
i'm very pleased to say that sabrina
joins us on the program we're also
joined by power-ups programme consultant
at yahoo guys great to have you both on
the program and i'm afraid
yeah we're going to have to start with
sabrina bit of a mystique fan here in
the studio this morning
just just tell us a little bit about
about your involvement in all of this
it's
it it might seem slightly strange to
some people that
that black artist might need assistance
to to punch through or
to guard against racism given just how
influential
british black artists have been over the
past 40 50 60 years
i know it's a thing of as we can see
music is the language that everyone
speaks
but sometimes on the you know
on the lower levels and the people that
are making decisions they don't really
see
the difference or the struggle that
people of color and black go
through on a day-to-day trying to be in
the music industry
and with power up i love that it's
pushing the industry and breaking down
barriers and giving
support to up-and-coming artists that
need it
um yeah we will be with you in just a
second but sabrina tell us about then
your experience if indeed you had one
back when you were
with the girls in mystique i mean the
the strong look the great message that
you guys were putting forward
you know if we were only glancing at the
surface one might imagine that
you didn't experience any of these
problems i suspect that wasn't the case
though
no that wasn't the case we came up on a
small label an independent label that
you know saw our products and they love
what we've done
so they invested in us but major labels
they kind of just said no or said no
and we came up on a small independent
label and we came up through
the support of radio stations and djs
and
you know supporting us and put in there
you know us on the radio
and that's from them putting us on the
radio
we became mystique that everyone knows
about but
behind the scenes racism was very very
much there and i've spoken about that
on another program about racism in the
industry
and that's the only thing that we need
to
continue to break down i hope as i said
in like 10 or
20 years this is a conversation that we
should be happy because as you said
black music has always been and is still
here but it just needs support
and the artist needs support to go
forward
and feel happy about it
well let's let's bring in yahoo who was
nodding along with you there i mean what
what
what
assistance can the the power up scheme
give it's a
is it about identifying artists just
just on the cusp of success or is it
holding their hand through through the
whole process
well it's it's it's multi-faceted really
and for the participant program which we
we've just launched today
um it's about grant giving so financial
support but also
marrying that with support around the
barriers that these individuals will
face
and again it's not just for artists it's
for industry professionals
so it's looking at things like capacity
building training
network you know making sure that
there's a support network and there's a
sharing of resources
and we've got some great partners
involved in power up as well so they're
all
contributing to make sure that these
individuals get the support they deserve
and are you know to no pun intended
while powered up properly
to be able to face some of the
challenges that they are and they will
face within the music industry yeah give
us that give us an
impression or a flavor of the problems
we've heard of course from sabrina about
what it can be like for the artist
but for the executives working within
the industry as well that there are
institutional racist barriers that they
have to break through but
what are those well setting up power
we've done you know extensive research
speaking to over 80 black music
and professionals both creators and and
um
people behind the scenes and what came
out
from everybody was you know there's
there's barriers whether it just be
um you know prejudice or you know
blatant racism
but then you've got you know lack of
opportunity um
lack of you know fair resources on
projects that they may be doing whether
they are
within um a certain genre or not
and less funding goes to black leather
organizations and individuals creative
or non-creative
and it's just it's just a lot about the
unfair reflection because again
you know you said it before black
music creators and industry
professionals are contributing so much
to this industry but yet the
opportunities and the compensation
and the treatment doesn't reflect that
positive and contribution
so yet there's a myriad of um
of challenges of barriers and of
experiences which need to be addressed
i mean sabrina you you talked about you
know being centered to a smaller label
the support you got from from peers
within the community
we're going to fast forward a few years
to where we are right now it
it does almost feel like we have you
know black music creators
making their own music and being able to
get it out there through youtube through
insta
through any kind of social media i mean
they're creating their own market
in the absence of perhaps the type of
assistance that power up might be able
to provide
yeah they are i mean they've had to find
another
way in order for their music to be out
because as
you know y'all said they haven't had the
support so
what i love about power up is giving the
support
and giving a you know a
a selection of people that will help to
propel them
forward and not leave them in the same
place and
you know just break down the barriers
that need to
be broken now not tomorrow
and and i'm going to give you the last
word because we are just running out of
time
just a word from you to people who might
be watching look to the success you had
but who've also heard about the the
struggles that you and the girls had as
well i mean what reassurance would you
provide that
this is an industry you want to get in
this is an industry that you want to
succeed in
it's i say music is the language
that speaks to many many people and if
it's something that you want to do
stick to it power up is here to
help you to power you up to have
everything you need advice mentoring
from other artists you know just
mentoring in a place
of a place of peace in the industry
where you can go and you can have
conversation and you can
find out new things and get to know so
power up
is definitely a new channel that needed
to be done
and i'm glad to be a part of it so if
anyone
feels like music is their thing or
they've been trying
in music what i like about power up is
that it doesn't come with
an age of you have to only be this age
it's
wide open so if you go to prs you can go
on to power up
put in your applications and
everyone's ready to help you and that's
a good thing